How you going, mate? What's up, man?
You're a Muslim? Yeah, definitely.
Alhamdulillah. How you going? What's
your problem with Islam? That Paul is
more reliable than Muhammad. Do you
believe in Paul as you're a prophet or
something? Yeah. So Paul is a prophet.
Who said Paul's a prophet? You yourself
or is that come from someone else? Well,
he received revelation from God. He
performed miracles and prophesied and
Paul was sent as a message. Miracles.
Paul performed miracles. Yeah. What
miracle did Paul perform? He healed a
paralyzed kid. He healed a paralyzed
kid. Yeah. Or man, sorry. He healed a
paralyzed man. So, where in the Bible
does it say Paul healed a paralyzed kid?
Acts chapter 14. The Bible that Paul
read. No. Luke wrote this. And isn't
that according to Luke? Written by Paul?
No. Luke is a different person from
Paul, my brother. This is fair enough.
It's You believe in the Bible? We don't.
The Bible's irrelevant to me. Why? So
what so how do you get Paul to be a
prophet when he unalived the early
Christians? Well and persecuted them.
Yeah. He uh he changed his he changed
his ways because of the revelation that
came to him because of the revelation
that came to him. He um stopped
persecuting Christians and became a
Christian and started preaching the
message of Jesus. Was he not um going
against the message of Jesus according
to Jesus's brothers? He was going
against the message of Jesus before he
became a Christian. Once he became a
Christian, he was preaching the message
of Jesus. Do you think Paul's above
Jesus? No. Jesus uh is on another level.
He's the Lord. So like Jesus is greater
than Abraham, Moses, obviously Muhammad.
Wasn't Jesus a man approved by Lord?
Isn't Jesus a man approved by Lord?
Yeah. So how does it make him Lord if
he's being approved by Lord? He's being
approved by God the Father and he's the
Lord. He's the ruler of heaven and
earth. So he approved of himself. I just
said the father, brother. So So the
father just just to be clear because he
you know I don't I don't want us to get
too uh too carried away off subject but
um just just to be clear the foundations
of Yeah, I know.
Dra. So what's up? So you have Paul who
used to persecute the Christians and
after he be after he became a messenger
he be he became a Christian and actually
took care of them and preached to them
and helped them. Muhammad he wasn't
persecuting Jews or Christians before
his revelation but after his revelation
he began to persecute the Jews and
Christians. So why do you believe that
Muhammad is a prophet? There's no record
of there's no record of that. Yeah. In
chapter 9 29, he gives the command to
fight the Jews and Christians and make
them pay the Jizia. That's That's not
That's not Prophet Muhammad. It isn't.
So Muhammad didn't Muhammad didn't give
the order to write the Quran. No,
Muhammad didn't write the Quran. I I
didn't say Muhammad wrote it, but
Muhammad's reciting it, right? No, you
said he said it. Quran's is the
creator's words, not I don't I don't
believe that. I don't believe that. But
we both believe but we both agree that
you don't have to believe. I I know we
we both we both agreed, Dar, that
Muhammad was reciting the verse, right?
Yeah. That was revealed to him. So
Muhammad did say it. So Muhammad did say
it, correct? I say it. I read the Quran.
So Muhammad said in chapter 9 29 to go
and fight the people of the book, the
Jews and Christians, until they pay the
Jiza and feel themselves sedues simply
because they don't believe. So yeah,
that was because he didn't want to and
the creator was telling him, "No, you
are Well, he did want to. He did want
to. It wasn't a time of war. The
Christians wasn't warning. He's not
saying it. When I read it, it's not me
saying it. So, why why do you still
believe he's a prophet when he goes out
and gives the command to persecute the
Jews and Christians? Because of his
prophecies, they've all come true.
Prophets give prophecies. Oh, so because
he's a prophet, it's okay for him to
persecute the Jews and Christians. No,
no, he's a prophet. Full stop. And he's
been tried and tested as a prophet.
Okay. So, it looks like persecution is
not what makes someone a true prophet or
not. Oops. Oh, what happened there,
mate? What happened? Sorry. Hold on.
It's my wife. So, anyway. Oh, hold on.
Hey, sweetheart. Hang on. Why you got
unknown numbers with your wife calling?
All right. Um, I don't want to get
sidetracked. Let's just get back to Paul
before Paul. So, first, hold on, D.
Excuse me. Sorry, D. Sorry, Dra. I don't
Sorry. Excuse me. What's up? It's okay.
I'm I'm the host of the show, so I'm I
direct where we go here. So, I just want
to make sure that we highlight. At
first, you brought up persecution as a
problem for Paul. When I bring up
persecution as a problem for Muhammad,
you're like, "Oh," you're like, "Or no,
he's a he's a prophet, so you know, he
could do that." Okay, fine. So,
persecution is not what is not a point
against Paul anymore because it doesn't
work against Muhammad even though he
persecuted folk. So, what makes Paul
what makes Paul not not a prophet, but
Muhammad is? We have we don't have
record of the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. But we do have record. You
have 929. No, you're talking about times
of war. The prophet wasn't worried. The
Christians was the Christians weren't at
war. The Christians weren't at war.
Yeah. This why did Paul and I love them
all. Take care of yourself. What's up,
Yaha? Yeah, I disagree. Why the topic?
Well, Paul encouraged polytheism while
Muhammad encouraged belief in one God.
Really? Yeah. How many creators did
Muhammad preach about? He preached one
God, one creator. One creator. Yeah. The
creator of the universe. There's only
one creator of the universe. So if he if
he taught that there were multiple
creators of life, is he teaching
polytheism? Well, there isn't many
different creators of life. I
understand. If he taught that there were
many creators of life, is he a
polytheist? Like many, what do you mean
by many creators of life? What does that
mean? Like creating life. Yeah. Like God
does. Like creating life. If he taught
that there are multiple creators of
life, is he a polytheist? Well, yeah.
Yeah, he'll be teaching many gods. And
if you're saying there's many gods, then
yeah, many creators of life cuz to be a
creator of the creator of life is god
alone. Would you agree? I would say
yeah, but all other things can can give
life to things like and lower forms not.
No only the only one that's giving life
is God. For example, for example, like
uh I would say like a like for example a
prophet who resurrects the dead, they
are giving life to that body. Who's
giving life to that body? Is it that
prophet or is it God doing it? It's by
the permission of God. The prophet's
doing it by by the permission of God.
saying that the prophet is the one
that's raising is giving life to the
dead. The prophet's doing that is
raising the dead doing it under the
permission of God. God is giving him
permission to do that. Okay. So, so just
to be clear, man, you guys Muslims will
it's it's amazing what you guys do. You
guys will proclaim monotheism and then
immediately jump into polytheism in just
like two seconds. You just told the
police if they do you just told me that
a prophet is the one who's giving life
to the dead. It's not God who's doing it
through the prophet. God is doing it
through them. Yeah. So, all right. So,
which one is doing? Is the prophet doing
it or is it God doing it? Both. They're
in uh both. All right. Got it. So,
they're in collaborate. They're in
partnership. So, Allah partners himself
with a prophet in giving life to the
dead sometimes, right? That's that's by
the permission of God. God is allowing
them to raise the dead. So by the
permission of Allah, hold on. By the
permission of Allah, he partners himself
with another in giving life to the dead,
right? No, he's not. He's giving them
permission to raise the dead for example
in would you say that in your paradigm?
The reason why I'm not allowing you to I
I know you are because you're running
from the question that I just asked you.
Well, I want to ask a clarifying
question on your The only clarifying
question is is the question that I asked
you, brother. That's the only clarifying
question that's on the table right now.
Mike, is this a dialogue or you can't
answer my question? It's a It's a
dialogue that you showing you can't
answer my question. I'm asking you and
you're clear. I want to clar I want But
you but but in in asking me, you're not
answering the question that I proposed
to you. You're jumping away to something
else. I'll answer I'll answer the
question, but I want You're going to
answer the question first and then maybe
jump to something else. That's just how
this works, my brother. You said you
said that Allah collaborates himself
with the prophet in raising the dead.
You said no. The prophet the pro the
prophet works with the grace which Allah
So did you or did you not say out of
your
mouth that God collaborates with the
prophet? Did you say that? No. The the
prophet works in the will of God. You
didn't say that. So what I meant by that
was that the prophet does the will of
God. Did you say that? Yeah. I said what
I meant by that. I'm clarifying what I
meant by that. Okay. Cuz I don't want to
disturb me. All right. So I I'll ask it
very again nice and simple. I I I would
have to repeat myself. Well, we we'll
see. Does Allah partner himself with the
prophet in raising the dead? What do you
mean by partner himself? That's
ambiguous. What does that mean? The
partner himself that he doesn't do it
alone. Yeah. The prophet is doing is
doing the will of God. By partner you
are you saying like worship? No. By
worship will that I'm saying that he
doesn't do it alone. that God is not
raising the dead by himself. He's also
he's doing it with a prophet. He's doing
it through the prophet. He's doing it
through the prophet. Okay. So, the
prophet's not doing it. It's God doing
it through him. Well, of course, the
prophet has a role in it. He's obeying
God. So, would say that he the prophet
obeyed God and God did it through him.
Okay, I got you. So, if uh so when it
comes to creating life, you're saying
that Allah is not the only creator of
life, but also prophets create life as
well, right? So yeah, God can do it
through the prophets. Like he did like
he did I didn't ask about doing it
through the prophets. I'm asking about
Yeah, he did it. He did it through He
did it through He can do it. For
example, you're going to bring the clay
birds. I know where you're going with
this. So God did it through Jesus. Does
Does it say that God did it through
Jesus or does it say Jesus did it?
That's the proper ex Jesus. Does it say
that Jesus did it? Where you getting
interpretation from? Um the Quran's
plain words when he says, "I make So if
I go to John 17:3 and I go I'm sorry.
I'm I'm sorry. Yaha, does Jesus say, "I
make for you a bird from clay," or does
he say, "God is going to make for you a
bird from clay through me?" Yeah. So,
there's proper exesus in the in in the
Quran. So, who's making the bird from
clay from the Yeah. For for example,
Mark 10, who's making the bird from
clay? Stop running to the Bible. Stop
running to the Bible. Read the text.
You're going to you're going to you're
going to Watch your head, brother. Watch
your head. Get going on and get out of
here. Where are you getting your inter
interpretation from? Uh the Quran. It
says it. Yeah, but you don't understand
that, do you? Unlike Muslims, I'm a
Christian and as a Christian, and this
isn't to all Muslims, but for the
majority of you that I've engaged with,
the difference between us is that I have
reading comprehension and you don't.
You're unable to comprehend the words
that's on the page in front of you. I am
because I went to school and I know
words and I know what words mean and I
know how sentence structure works and I
I can I can read. So when I see Jesus
say, "I make for you a bird from clay."
Jesus is making the bird from clay
himself. He's the one doing it. That's
what he said. Oh, but you need proper
exogesis of that. No, what you mean is
is Jesus. You need to read into it. You
don't want to take the text for what it
says. You You want to read into the
text. That's the difference between us.
Huge difference. Tough man.